tigers sending willie peralta to the
mound tonight two and one pretty good
with the tigers want to come out and
get quick innings and get back on the
attack
right at jamer candelario adam played
perfectly one away
one away in here is donaldson
bullet to center so a couple of well-hit
balls here in the
first inning against willy peralta
there's the 01 to larnak and that's a
line drive to left center second
cut off by akil badu the throw into
third
[Music]
able to take it but they got him at
second base the cutoff
with candelario to paredes to naba
greedy trevor larnak
the veteran jay happ 16 starts this
season you see the numbers right there
has been
better recently and has done a good job
against the tigers
broken bat looper and it's going to be
got him played well but badou's speed
beats half to the bag there was no
chance for jay happ the lefty to get a
kill but do it first
there goes badou they've got him picked
off safe but they won't get him
you know pitchers try and be sneaky so
they don't go that fast at first but
you're the first mission to say get it
over here
you can see by doing they're easy the
ball two strikes on grossman
and the pitch he struck him out swinging
he got a high fast ball grossman's
bottom hand came off on that cut
glove on the right hip ball behind the
left as he gets the sign
from his catcher jeffers behind the
plate
down on a knee setting up inside the o2
swinging in a miss fastball up
how about that that's miguel cabrera two
fastballs up in the strike zone get
a couple of strikeouts to end the first
here's the rise had a great at bat now
drive to the gap and left center field
won't be caught all the way to the fence
and arise spinning around first
goes to second with a first pitch double
and the twins continue
to hit the ball hard against willie
peralta
cruz a bouncer to third candelario gets
one on his own and then throws crews out
across the diamond
nice candelario's been busy and he's
been up to the challenge and so has the
tigers defense
welcome to the bottom of the third jake
rogers
leads off that's a fair ball down the
right field line
rogers will hustle for second he's in
there
with a head first slide a double to lead
off the third
jake rogers second double of the series
the one sent to center field
that should do the job rogers tags
tigers have the early lead on jonathan
scobe's sacrifice live
here's miguel cabrero with two men
aboard
a bullet to left hill around third
he's gonna hurry the throw on its way
won't get him
that rbi single for miguel cabrera
because derek hill has
jets on the back of his spikes
two-nothing tigers here's gamer
candelario
candelario lifts one to left center
field on the run is a rise
off the wall grossman is home cabrera
held up at third
jamer candelario's got an rbi double
and the tigers have opened it up it's
three nothing
there you go strikeout number three
starts the fourth for willie peralta
there he goes it's low oh no they called
him out
and a double play
peralta punches out kepler looking and
then
rogers makes sure everybody is on high
alert
because of his right arm throws out
polanco
easily dan the inning
[Music]
backhanded by simmons in the air strong
throw across to kirilov
what a play by andrewton simmons on the
grass to his right
wow this is impressive this is jeter
like right here
jonathan scope who drove in a run in the
third with a sacrifice fly
fly ball left field up the battle scope
watch it fly
[Music]
monster home run to left number 17 for
jonathan scope not much doubt when it
left the bat
five-nothing tigers in the fifth well
that's a quad triple uh uh buggy whip
right there
and called it right because that ball
was a scorcher
without in our hurry hope you didn't
hurt anybody out there willie peralta
again a fantastic outing for him so far
the other way oh what a play by
candelario
short turns it are you kidding me it's
as good a double play
as you will ever see that ball came off
smoking hot candelario picked it with a
backhand
made a perfect throw to zach short for
turn
two and the tigers twist their third
double play of the day
that was awesome timing is good meaning
your right foot goes down about the time
the ball is hit you have a seamless
transition to motor around there goes
turns on it deep to left field see
ya another two run shot for the tigers
and jamer candelario delivers here
with two out in the seven boy have a day
jamerr how about that looking for that
power a severe buggy whip another bomb i
mean you know you we've talked about
scopes home runs there's another one
that got out
in a hurry
popped it up on a 2-0 pitch scope
is under it and puts it away they like
to feel it
slow chopper cut off by candelario what
a play
makes it look easy but that was not easy
to get a speedy simmons there's two away
candy's got a lot of rhythm today
doesn't it everything's just right you
see his body's moving he's in
control he did he climbed the ladder and
struck him out
buck farmer retires the twins and keeps
it scoreless from minnesota seven
nothing detroit
the one two swinging a miss he stayed
with the changeup sir makes sense good
job
alex lang after the fourth pitch walk
and then throwing ball one
let's kill off back-to-back change-ups
to end the at-bat here's the 2-2
rolled over to second shorts turn
not in time two-way lang against kepler
the 1-0 fly ball center field
hill is back he's got it and the tigers
sweep the twins their seventh sweep of
the year
their most since 2016 and they boast
their fourth shutout
of the season as well fun weekend
outstanding stuff